know if i have a favorite thing about my
suit i don't know i just don't even know
i'm wearing it
let's just say i've gone back to set and
there have been
articles of my costume that are a little
wet so i had like these mantis that i
don't know it was it was real bad it was
like man panties they were terrible
on the positive side it's stretchy
they're up here
i have a fantastic body
my favorite thing to watch from any of
the soups while we're shooting is them
doing the like math of should i go to
the bathroom now
because it's always it's a situation
with all of them hey
do you have a second we've been getting
some super secrets from your co-stars so
i'm curious to know tell me your
favorite thing about your suit
and the most uncomfortable thing about
your suit oh there's no secrets it's a
wetsuit basically
uh that's the no the i guess
on the positive side it's stretchy and
it's sleeveless and at least that like
allows like i'm cooler
in it you know in the summertime and so
it allows some airflow
are you serious okay so my favorite
thing actually is that we shoot what we
have
formerly shot in the summertime in
toronto and so
all of the suits are dying and
nearing heat stroke you could argue and
i am in basically a bathing suit like
challenge feeling breezy so that's my
favorite part
you all right huh yeah yeah yeah i'm
good i'm good i'm fast baby like i'll
roll you know
my favorite thing about this suit is the
chest plate i think the chest plate is
awesome
i think it's very well made and it looks
amazing and it works very well
and i think the concept of it is kind of
cool too it's like
i don't know i i guess i would sort of
need like some type of face shield or
something if i'm running at the speeds
that i would actually be running at but
i think the amount of things i would be
hitting is is crazy but that's sort of
what the chest plate signifies like a
windshield sort of
i'm the new girl i don't know if i have
a favorite thing about my suit
nothing i don't know i just don't even
know i'm wearing it
wait no they're up here
i have um i have
i have um a fantastic
body it's true though fun it's fun to
change it up i've had this body my whole
life
it's nice to have another body you are
fun it's been a hoot if you had to try
on someone else's suit who would you
want to try on
we made really quick uh yeah no because
i i
imagine that it's like i've spent two
canadian
toronton toronton two summers in toronto
sweating
my life away in that homeland suit and
queen maeve always looks cool and
refreshed so
i'd give that a shot that's right maeve
what's the most uncomfortable part about
your suit
everything my least favorite thing would
be
it's not like an old technology we don't
really use it in the suit anymore but we
nicknamed it
the mantis which
[Laughter]
okay i'm sorry there were these like
tiny little
um they weren't really underwear because
they go on like over top of my underwear
but they had little hooks in it to like
hold my
shirt down so that it wouldn't like
ride you know if i ran or whatever my
shirt would come out from under my my
pants so i had like these
mantis that i don't know it was it was
real bad it was like man panties they
were terrible
but uh we don't really use them anymore
now there's a zipper system and all
kinds of other stuff
thank god but the mantis were uh they
were my least favorite
there's no need for language it's
stretchy but it's still a wetsuit it's
ty likes
you know sitting down is just not fun
it's just it's just the whole thing i
remember like i'm zipping that thing and
like you know and laying back but
i've gotten used to it for sure you get
used to it you're definitely feeling
character in it and it's it's trust me i
think anthony has it the worst from what
i've seen
carrying around his little cooler bag of
ice and stuff yeah
the uncomfortable place starts at the
neck and ends at the end of the boots
really now the best thing about that is
amazing
and they're totally functional we can
handle the comfort level like
you know we're just being little baby
actors
wonderful great
all right great
i think this is going great and he has a
little cooling shirt
so he can plug in on near his behind
so during breaks he gets a little plug
in and they send cold water
through his body to cool him down i was
like that's amazing it's true
that's cool that's a cool little fun
fact
it is it is and it actually is pretty
functional and it works pretty well but
the problem is the
the battery pack is noisy the motor is
noisy so we got to take it off
when we're shooting but the things you
do to be a suit
you dude can i tell you a secret my
least favorite part
okay i know it might not look like it
but
going to the bathroom just going to pee
in that suit
takes about 25 minutes because
of the ext it's so tight
and it's so little the way they need to
wind the microphone in me i'm like
wired up and the process of taking it on
and putting it off
it's left me in positions where let's
just say i've gone back to set
and there have been articles of my
costume
that are a little wet it happens
it happens you know girls have it hard
right my favorite thing to watch from
any of the soups while we're shooting is
them doing the like
math of should i go to the bathroom now
because it's always it's a situation
with all of them but they're all just
like
us it's amazing you should look away
jack when you were
standing on set of episode three covered
in
all that whale blood and guts yeah and
you got to look at your lovely
co-star erin in her gorgeous super suit
did you
ever for a moment think maybe i want a
suit
oh i want a suit i want a suit so bad
it's insane
i mean i was just jealous of aaron that
day because i
she was clean and i was just
covered in in guts you guys go ahead you
guys go ahead i'm good
we have shot with the soups before
and we're always like why aren't you
bloody
there's something wrong with this it
always feels like they're coming from a
spa or something right
they're so clean they're pristine like
like anthony just finished the nail
salon and then he's
it's so it's always so funny shooting
with the seven but i mean
starlight i mean her entire outfit is
white
and i am covered in blood constantly so
whenever we're you know taking breaks in
between scenes or something i
i have to take extra care not to go
too close to her and when i'm like
passing her a drink or something i'm
like here
and then she's like oh wait i'm like
okay never mind i'll put it down here
no way
sticky blood you know
i never ever want to be in any of those
suits ever what about you carl
yeah super suits are not all uh cracked
up to be i mean first of all i mean if
you just talk to tony you know he's
attached to a cooling suit underneath
that to keep him cool he's wearing
a bunch of latex and he has to be very
very aggressive about his manscaping
because
those latexers show up everything so no
we we're quite happy uh
with our uh without being hardy gets a
full body wax
yeah all right enough we do not have
time for this
no i want a suit so bad there is one
issue of the boys comic book
where hughie is going undercover in the
g-men which is kind of like our
universe's x-men
and he's wearing a super small
ill-fitting suit for him and i just want
to find a way
to maybe not even give huey powers but
just have him masquerade as a superhero
would be
really nice great cool totally one two
[Music]
three
you